mélina dufrègne elle a fait chez
l'infirmière libérale et membre du
collectif sos soignants en danger
bonjour mélina dufrègne lâche michel
merci d'être avec nous sur rt france
vous êtes mobilisés contre le courant
des virus racontez nous votre quotidien
oui notre quotidien nous avons donc mis
en place une tournée coffee
nous nous sommes donc organisé en train
de firmes hier dans un même secteur
nous avons regroupé deux villages
rivesaltes espira de l'agly et nous
sommes mises en lien aussi avec des
médecins
donc notre quotidien et par rapport à
l'état l'état nous a fourni sa pour
faire face au co gide 19 l'état nous
fournissent à comme vous le savez tous
pour pouvoir soigner dignement et ne pas
prendre de risque pour nous et nos
patients il faut tout un matériel un
matériel que nous ne possédons pas
l'état met en danger tout le monde que
ça soit nos patients comme nous mêmes
donc voilà nous avons décidé à travers
cette campagne de 2,2 de cette campagne
de nous mettre à nu parce que le
gouvernement nous envoie nul face à
cette pandémie
c'est la bonne solution pour interpeller
le gouvernement sur le manque de
protection justement cette vidéo choc
qui se met à nu devant le gouvernement
pour interpeller à tous tout ce manque
de protection oui oui j'ai façon le
gouvernement ne nous entend pas bon ça
absolument pas entendu comme les
hospitaliers nous ne sommes pas entendus
puisque nous en sommes encore à ce qu'on
donne des masques qui date de 2001
comment vous expliquer ce manque de
dialogue
comment je l'expliqué déjà pas ne
serait-ce que par nos représentations
nous représentons qui sont entre autres
l'ordre infirmier qui sont
éventuellement les syndicats personne ne
ne porte ne portent notre voix auprès du
gouvernement et jeu ce n'est pas que ce
gouvernement là qui est responsable de
la situation dans laquelle nous sommes à
l'heure actuelle ça fait 15 ans 20 ans
que la santé en france se porte mal vous
sentez pas du tout soutenu par le
gouvernement aux là on l'a bien compris
ce que d'après vous
cette crise sanitaire va changer les
choses je l'espère je l'espère comment
comment justement par quels moyens et
bien en prenant conscience en prenant
conscience dans des conditions dans
lesquelles nous travaillons et le
gouvernement nous envoie nous quoi il
faut quand même se rendre compte que
tout ce matériel nous le possédons pas
on est obligé de se fédérer les uns les
autres
la seule chose entre guillemets qui a eu
2 4 bien dans cette pandémie
c'est que nous les libéraux nous sommes
autonomes nous avons des cabinets les
uns les autres
en général nous nous côtoyons pas et la
face face à cette épreuve commune de
tous les soignants de france nous nous
fédérerons alors il ya une peur
j'imagine pour pour les passions pour
vous qui est infirmière libérale les
passions que que vous inspecté à chaque
jour il ya une peur chez les patients
mais aussi chercher des aides soignants
j'imagine oui il ya une peur chez tout
le monde chez les patients chez nous
même et dans nos familles a pas ce qu'on
peut on tout ramener à notre domicile on
peut on peut contaminer tout le monde
quel est le ressenti de vos patients
vis-à-vis du commis 19 que vous avez
l'habitude de deux d'examiner il
ils ont peur très honnêtement ils sont
peur les ont peur ils ont peur aussi
d'entendre que la cinquième ou sixième
puissance mondiale n'a pas de napa de
réanimation suffisante il faut savoir
qu'il y à un choix et vous le savez
pertinemment ça se dit c'est une réalité
il y à un choix dans les gens que nous
soignons et que nous allons soigner
merci beaucoup mais lina dufrègne la
fléchette je rappelle que va être
infirmière libérale et membre du
collectif sos soignants en danger